so we get we bought go to one house I
satisfy the loans in public record I
then turn around
I have no credit Garry Sullivan has no
credit okay but I have a house worth
$210,000 so I turn around and I go to
multiple banks and I borrow money I
borrow a hundred ninety thousand from
one bank 196 from another bank when I
guess that house yeah
so I bar like five loans it's like nine
hundred thousand and I borrowed another
four hundred thousand on the other house
so it's 123 million dollars so then I go
to all the closings within a few days of
each other one of the things that
happens in the mean time by the way is
that the other house that I had one of
those lenders did alone they did a loan
on the second house and they caught that
they were in third position so that's a
loan for like a hundred and eighty
thousand one hundred seven eight hundred
eighty something like that and so I get
a phone call saying hey is this Gary
Sullivan I said yeah it is Gary Sullivan
he says listen my name is you know let's
say mr. Thompson from Washington Mutual
and we caught a hundred and fifty or
160,000 on your house on that house okay
he said and it turns out that we found
we realized that there's another loan on
the house we're in second position and
this is an issue and we're contemplating
calling the FBI not sure what you want
to do about that but I wanted to see if
there was an explanation I said okay
well wait a second now mr. Thompson
let's talk about this let's not get
crazy
it's not you know so I said look let me
let me call you back
I think what's in both of our interest
is that we get Washington Mutual money
back as soon as possible and he says why
I agree so let's let's work on that so I
Drive to my corporate lawyer in Columbia
and I explained the situation to him and
he says so you're saying you've got four
or five loans on this one house I'm like
yeah it's like like four hundred
thousand here's what about this other
house and I said oh I've got like nine
hundred thousand on that one and he goes
okay well Gary that's a problem and now
that's my lawyers there are two lawyers
in there like this I'm not like my
immediate problem is paying these guys
back the one six right now so let's pay
them back to one city and he goes okay
we can I'll uh I'll I'll call the guy so
he calls up and he says listen to you
know 160,000 he can work this out
let's work this out and I said okay and
you know we go back and forth and I'm
like look he wants to 160 I'm like look
I'll give him the 160 he's like whoa
they also want the prepayment penalty
I'll pay the prepayment penalty okay
well they also want the first month or
less ridiculous it's only been a week
I'm like I'll pay the first month's pay
come on man right so they come up with
whatever 165 I forget at that number so
I say okay okay okay so he hangs at the
phone he says great you got to go get a
cashier's check
I remember they wanted me to go into the
bank like a Washington Mutual branch and
bring them I said I'm not going in so I
said I'll get a cashier's check bring it
to you he says okay they write up an
agreement where they prompt they they
agree that it's a it's not a criminal
matter it's a creative financing error
and that it's a civil matter and that
it's being taken care of so they felt
the paperwork no big deal they fax it
back and forth I sign it
I remember the lawyer this is the funny
part about this is that the two lawyers
are sitting there and he says okay well
what are we gonna do about about the
other mortgages and I go what do you
mean he was Gary you've got multiple
mortgages on all these properties I went
right right and he said well this is an
issue he's what if these other lenders
find out about the mortgages and I went
well I leave town and he goes and he
said no and they laugh they go like Oh
Gary that's not gonna work
they've got your date of birth they have
your social security number yeah they're
gonna find you and I go you're assuming
I'm Gary Sullivan right and the look on
their faces was just like yeah they
didn't even think of that right man and
he goes well we'll cross that bridge
when it comes I said that's right let me
get the check I go get the check I come
back I give him the check and I remember
he said okay well I need money for my
fee and I said well what's your fee it's
a couple hours work and he goes I think
$1500 is
good I said okay so I pull out counting
out cash goes well we typically ten will
take cash I take a check and I said
after what you just heard you'd take a
check from me yeah he pays them that was
good they're good we're all happy I keep
pulling money out of the bank
Becky's happy Becky and I decide once we
pull all the money out because we're
close to getting to all the money at
this point I've been pulling out money
we got six seven hundred thousand
dollars I'm out of the bank we still
have a chunk of other money we've got
got a chunk of money so um so we're that
we've decided we're gonna move to
Houston Texas
so she's moved to Houston Texas
she lives in Houston now downtown
Houston amazing building and so she's in
Texas and she has already in taxes yeah
she was in Texas so I go into the bank
one day I go into Wachovia
walk into Wachovia as Gary Sullivan
typically I when I walked in a place I
only had information on me that was
specific to that person right so it'll
get mixed up or right happen to have a
happen to have a Michael Eckert driver's
license in my my wallet I walk in I go
up to tell her I said any nine grand in
cash she goes okay
she turns red she's I got to get
authorization for that I said no problem
she walks in the back five minutes ago
by I'm standing there the whole place is
crowded next thing I know boom somebody
pulls my hand behind my back pulls the
other hand behind my back I turn around
there are these massive massive
sheriff's deputies I mean I'm I'm five
six I'm five seven with a good pair of
shoes I mean these guys are huge so I'm
like hey they go hey they said hey they
grabbed my drop my ID and they said
you're being detained
mister mr. Sullivan you're being
detained come with us they put the cuffs
on me they walk me in the back
everybody's staring they sit me down in
the
office I'm sitting there and I said
what's this about they go all we know is
to detain you five minutes later a
detective shows that they were waiting
for the detective and I heard detective
I thought okay FBI because I knew the
FBI was already looking for me and by
this point when I left Atlanta and the
Secret Service has gotten involved
mm-hmm and the Secret Service had placed
me on the Secret Service's most-wanted
list because the Secret Service deals
with aggravated with identity theft I
didn't with anything to do with the with
the infrastructure of currency or money
of any kind okay you know which is a lot
of banking right they basically took
over a massive amount of the FBI once
the FBI kind of shifted to terrorism
they took over a massive amount of that
so so uh you know I know they're looking
mm-hmm and so anyway I go back I'm
waiting I'm handcuffed the detective
walks in I'm thinking FBI Secret Service
they walk in the guy says he walks in
and he says hey mr. Sullivan you know
I'm whatever his name was you know
Richard I'm John Richards and detective
Richards and I say okay and he says we
were you know we were contacted by
Wachovia is the head of Wachovia is
fraud department we understand that
you've got multiple loans on a piece of
property that you borrowed money from
one of the loans you took out was from
Wachovia and you've got you have using
you've got three loans on one piece of
property I actually had six loans on
three yeah so I looked up and I'm and I
go I remember I said is that illegal and
he went you know I don't know and I
don't know right then thinking I'm
walking out of here
yeah I'm good all I got to do is
convince this guy I can get out of here
he goes you're not under arrest I go I'm
not I feel like I'm under arrest I show
him the cuts here oh yeah can you take
those off him so they take take the
cuffs off and I said what's going on he
goes I don't know let's get Wachovia is
had a security on the phone they get him
on the phone he started saying this guy
is running a shotgunning scam he's
borrowing so many mortgages on the house
we couldn't catch it in time and he's
removing all the money
cash and he said you're removing all the
money in cash I said I am removing any
cash and he said why and I said well
because I work for a day labor company
and I had I pull out my I have a I have
a little business card day labor it says
I'm a site manager Gary solvent site
manager labor on demand and I said it's
a day and what happens is I said week we
cut these guys checks and they had to go
cash the checks and they charge them
like 10% so I usually just cashed that
their checks for them I said I mean I
don't know if that's illegal and you
know that's that's nice that's fine I'm
like okay so the guy says listen he this
he that he's he's got multiple first
mortgages and I went ok well I read
every one of the mortgages I took out
none of them said first mortgage because
it's actually the placement of the
mortgage that determines whether it's a
first second or third mortgage and not
it doesn't really say anything on the
mortgage
so he's like he's like you know he's
he's I'm unraveling his little thing
he's trying to convince him and I'm
saying no no I read the things it didn't
say why didn't he take them all out from
the same Bank I said well you know I
don't know I came to Wachovia I know
Wachovia knows they're in first position
so I said I borrowed a first mortgage
from Wachovia I told them that I needed
like half a million dollars so the loan
officer Wachovia had a friend at and I
go shoot what was the name what's the
name of the other lender and he goes he
and he tells me he's like Oh son trust
I'm like right son trust and they gave
me a second mortgage well the girl at
SunTrust said she could give me
additional money for a sec and for a
home equity line of credit this guy
that's not all Mike what do you like I
cried at he's lying he and I'm like look
this is what happened and I signed that
and they gave me the money and I don't
understand what about you wrong mm-hmm
and he's like yeah I'm not sure what the
what he did wrong I mean sounds to me I
go sounds to me like they got a problem
at the bank didn't do anything wrong so
he's screaming and then he goes look at
his ID look at his ID and he goes okay
he looks at the I only had an ID not a
driver's license because I had a vehicle
that was in the name Michael Eckert hmm
so I didn't need driver's license and he
goes yeah um he is it starts with zero
zero zero he has no no our our our ID
start with zero zero zero he was it's a
fake ID
you know I ran him through NCIC it's his
real ID
he is Gary Sullivan and I went oh now
I'm not Gary Sullivan I oh come on man
what are we doing here are you doing and
he goes so if you already got that guy
you already know you like your gold oh
the two sheriff's are still standing
that deputies are still there yeah so he
goes he's screaming a hollering and he's
in he's telling him to calm down I go
look man I think they got a problem that
Bank I wouldn't know how to do this I
said I work for a labor company what I'm
gonna trick the bank of a half a million
dollars come on
I own two houses here in the area and he
goes that's right you did yeah he owns
two houses he yeah so he's look I don't
even know if he's committed a crime yet
I'm gonna bring him downtown we're gonna
fill out a police report and I'm gonna
see what the district attorney says he
hangs up on the guy guys furious yeah I
get up to leave and he says Gary this is
an assault Carolina ID do you have a
driver's license and I went I do but
it's in Nevada I don't know if Gary
Sullivan has one in Nevada right no clue
he's a homeless guy right almost yeah
you know prostitute yeah just given
reached around 7:00 so the the detective
says he owes oh that's right he was
you're from I forgot you're from Las
Vegas and I write then remember that he
had said he pulled me through NCIC so he
knows Gary Sullivan's been arrested
twice for prostitution oh [ __ ] so I
thought no I looked over the deputies
and these guys are glancing at each
other smiling and I thought don't think
you're a male prostitute I was a male
process and the guy goes one of the cops
grabs the ID and says I'll check to see
if he's got a driver's license he walks
off he comes back and he says yeah he's
got a valid driver's license in Nevada
and the deputy goes he checks out use
everything's good it's valid he was here
yeah yes it's valid he's well it says
he's five foot ten and they all look at
me and I go we'll fellas with a good
pair of shoes
ah Gary follow us step back to the
police station so I'm driving back to
the police station with the cruiser
behind me and the deputy's car in the
front of me my phone rings and it's
Becky and I go hey what's going on
and she says oh my god I forgot like 40
missed calls why I oh my god what are
you doing what are you doing I said okay
I you're not gonna believe this
I said I just got detained I'm being
driven back to the police station I have
to fill out a police report and I
explain what happens and she goes get on
the interstate
get out of there kid I said I can't
there's a cop behind got to play this
out I said listen five minutes ago I was
in handcuffs I can do this I can get out
of this I'm good she's understand you're
number one on the secret services
most-wanted list they just raised you to
the number one you got it I said look I
can't I can't I said look the worst-case
scenario is this I'll get arrested you
get me a lawyer
get me out she goes I'm not getting you
out on bond I'm not getting you a lawyer
she goes I'm not risking everything I
have to try and get you out of jail
she's got all the money oh [ __ ] yeah so
I'm going so well I guess I'd better not
get arrested yeah so I hang up the phone
I go in there I fill out the police
report mm-hmm I wait he won't let me let
waiting his cue he says can you wait in
the hallway I gotta go talk to them to
the mic
whatever lieutenant whatever all right I
wait in the hallway in the hallway
there's all of these posters there's one
color poster which is my Secret
Service's most wanted poster a picture
of you a picture of me now keep in mind
I've had plastic with their real name on
it Oh
Mattox yeah after mine I've had plastic
surgery by this point I've had
liposuction I had a nose job
I had what's called a mini facelift I
got porcelain veneers I had two hair
grafts you know this isn't real
[Laughter]